I get energized when I see people
achieve high standards in anything we
all spend far too much time at work for
it not to have a deeper meaning all
great achievement is in happens only
when you have self belief and you have
confidence in yourself is you have to
fall in love with what you do when it
comes to culture what is fire for us as
a company is a learning living culture
really have to be slightly delusional
ah to be as you know an entrepreneur how
do i integrate my life and my work
because they think of these things
separate is not possible we have a very
clear vision of what it is that we're
trying to get done our customers are
gonna make choices that make the most
sense for them and they're not going to
be homogeneous choices in order to truly
go after the concept you need capability
here's an indian-born American business
executive he is currently the CEO of
Microsoft before becoming CEO of
Microsoft he was the executive vice
president of Microsoft's cloud and
enterprise group he Satya Nadella
and here are his top 10 rules for
success I think more than anything else
perhaps what's defines me is and this
I've also understood exposed is I'm a
lifelong learner I get energized when I
see people achieve high standards in
anything at work when somebody comes to
me with an idea that they have
implemented and it's something that I've
not seen before that's the thing that
gets me going I you know as I say I buy
more books than I can finish
I sort of sign up for online courses
more so then I can actually finish them
but I love it and thank God for these
new online courses where they even have
10 minute segments so at least a a sense
of accomplishment is much easier it's
like a cliff notes yeah I wish I had it
when I was growing up but I think that
that is perhaps more than anything else
that gives me the energy and it's not
just the learning for learnings sake
well I think we all in business in
particular thrive in is applied learning
to be able to take that our create
products create programs approaches to
how we work with
murrs and partners and excelling in them
and being able to sort of both do that
and more importantly learn from others
who are doing it is what I would say
defines me the most that notion of
finding the soul of a company it's
something that I constantly think about
in fact probably in my early 30s I was
doing very well at Microsoft and I had
this guy whom I worked for his name was
Doug burgum and he in fact he's - he was
a founder of Great Plains which you know
became our business applications
business and dynamics but the
fascinating thing was I was working for
him and one day he sort of looks at me
and he's you know he says hey are you
excited about work and he said something
that stuck with me which is we all spend
far too much time at work for it not to
have a deeper meaning and in some sense
he was sort of invoking that notion of
finding in work your own purpose in your
own soul and of course individually it
matters and I have always thought that
collectively the company has a soul
because it's made of people and I I
asked the question what is Microsoft
exist
what is that sensibility that we have
and that's what led me to rediscover in
our 40 years there's been this one
constant threat of empowerment and
that's why when I talk about our mission
that is our soul it is the impact
empowering every person and organization
on the planet to achieve more I've
always felt that I'm not I have
confidence I mean this is one of those
fascinating things right I've learned
which is all great achievement is in
happens only when you have self belief
and you have confidence in yourself but
there is this fine line between
confidence and hubris that I always felt
that
want to be on the side of confidence not
hubris and to assume destinations in my
mind is more hubris than confidence and
lastly perhaps most important of all is
you have to fall in love with what you
do because everything else then simply
becomes easy if you just are so
passionate about what you do one it
doesn't feel like work for sure and more
importantly it is perhaps the best way
to find meaning in what you do and I was
just thinking about so what's the list
way to capture it and I remember reading
this Gandhi port which I think is the
most appropriate way to capture it he
said something along the lines of saying
that live every day as if it's your last
day but learn as if you're going to live
forever the culture of a place is what I
think defines the pursuit of excellence
in other words you can sort of look at a
company and say while they're doing
great things but you've got to really
look underneath that and understand the
culture because that's what produces
whatever it is that you achieve in terms
of greatness and to me the concept that
there is one culture and you want to
change it by unfreezing it and freezing
it back again as a model itself I don't
think works there have got to be
enduring values but when it comes to
culture what is fire for us as a company
is a learning living culture the thing
that we have anchored on is this notion
of growth mindset it comes from you know
psychology there's enough Theory there
and if you take the posture that every
day I'm going to be better than the
previous day as individuals and as a
company that's the culture I want at
Microsoft and that'll serve us in fact
that's what's going to make us great
listeners learners and doors what are
the things that people talked a lot
about is what gets something to become
an entrepreneur you know it's just a
fascinating mindset right you really
have to be slightly delusional hard to
be a star you know an entrepreneur
because you have to suspend this belief
you all you have to believe about your
own idea and have deep passion to go
pursue it so in some sense quite
honestly before I knew advise I take a
lot of inspiration from what you're
doing now it takes a lot of guts it
takes a lot of energy
to be an entrepreneur and I think that
in the in their therein lies I think
your secret to success which is your
ability to overcome every constrain and
every obstacle and not and do it with
the boldness and the risk on nature of
it I think is fantastic if anything I
would say especially for entrepreneurs
is you might keep sustained that sense
of energy over a long period of time
because we all know and you are grounded
in it the mortality rate is super high
ah and that means you will be thrown
curveballs you know day in and day out
ah and you have to be able to overcome
that and so being a source of energy in
your small team especially if you're a
CEO of a startup I like to sort of
observe them a lot because uh you can't
have a bad day you're all the time you
know you get up in the morning you're
coding in the afternoon you're talking
to your investors in the evening you're
uh you know hiring and that's constant
sense of energy and passion for what
you're doing is what I think it takes
and to never give up which is what makes
you who you are in terms of the core
makeup and I think that for me I am
personally inspired by all that and I
think that even from a Microsoft culture
that's what really my dream is my thing
is not that okay we have you know a
large organization my hope is that every
team inside of Microsoft feels both that
sense of energy and empowerment uh and
goes about it who are your heroes or
heroines who do you look up to either
now or in the past many many different
um but there's this one gentleman I work
for his name was Doug burgum it was
actually the founder of a company called
Great Plains that we acquired and it is
sort of at one moment he told me this
which is look we spend far too much time
at work I mean I think back at it I mean
I've spent 24 years already at Microsoft
and for it to be just work it not to
have deep meaning would be a real waste
individually and so he sort of really
got me onto this path of trying to seek
in everything I do that what is the
sense of purpose and that I think is
what is inspiring you know because we
have this how do i integrate my life and
my work because the think of these
things is separate is not possible the
modern life doesn't allow us to do that
so therefore you gottem harmonize the
two and that's something that I've
learnt in over the years to me we have a
very clear vision of what it is that
we're trying to get done and I want to
stay true to that are we absolutely the
biggest bed we have is our organic bed
all wet always and even it's true even
for Michael and then on top of that
we'll look at any opportunity that fits
with where we want to get to what is it
that we can uniquely do what if anything
that I ask myself each day is
I don't want to be in every part of the
tech industry I want to be in things
that are big addressable markets where
Microsoft has a unique contribution to
make because I think that sense of
purpose and identity is what makes
companies successful not just doing
everything and so to me that's what will
drive whatever we do organically and
whatever you do in organically if you
look at our industry how is our industry
going to succeed it's only going to
succeed if we can add value to our
customers our customers are going to
make choices that make the most sense
for them and they're not going to be
homogeneous choices they're going to use
all of our different applications
they're going to use multiple platforms
and it's incumbent on us especially for
those of us who are platform vendors to
partner broadly to solve real pain
points our customers have so that's
really how I've approached it I don't
think of it as a zero-sum with anyone
competitive able to compete vigorously
in certain domains but the total
opportunity for us to take the power of
digital technology and empower every
person and every organization is so huge
that these partnerships I think really
only help amplify that and that's why
you should you know we're here we you
know we were at the Apple event I guess
last week and they're all testament to
sort of both what is it that is our
computing vision and also the realities
of our customers clearly there was a
concept that you fell in love with that
got you to create this startup now the
reality is that concept itself will
morph as you learn more about your
customers as you learn more about your
competition as you learn more about your
environment that concept itself will
evolve but the thing that from day one
that you will have to keep in mind is
the capability that you need to build to
chase after that concept have that
persistence and that capability building
is
perhaps even for a CEO of a hundred
thousand person company is as important
as the concept itself because sometimes
I think for a large company like us or
for a start-up we fall overly in love
with just the concept but in order to
truly go after the concept you need
capability and you have to sort of think
about the sort of the bandwidth that you
apply every day to building that
capability that means human capital in
our case I mean your recruitment the
amount of time you spend recruiting your
co-founder to the other employees is
perhaps the most important capability in
initial days but it goes a lot beyond
that thank you so much for watching I
made this video because paurav Sony
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know what you have such as top 10 rules
had the biggest impact on you leave it
in the comments and I will join in the
discussion
thank you so much for watching you need
to believe and I'll see you soon